[Musique]
pour combler ses besoins de main
d'oeuvre le québec doit maintenant se
tourner vers les travailleurs étrangers
est plus que jamais d'ailleurs romain
choi bonsoir mon général vous avez
analysé les chiffres et on constate que
le québec accueille de plus en plus de
travailleurs étrangers temporaires oui
c'est assez frappant en fait depuis 2010
est grosso modo le nombre de
travailleurs étrangers temporaires il a
doublé au québec en fait il a doublé en
l'espace de deux ans en est passé de 17
mille six cents à peu près en 2010 est à
33 34 milles en 2019 en 2020 la tendance
s'est maintenue pourtant il y avait les
frontières qui a été fermé dès le mois
de mars et 2021 on a les chiffres que du
premier semestre mais il ya déjà plus de
20000 on attend les chiffres à jour
évidemment du côté du gouvernement
canadien mais on peut donc prévoir une
forte hausse encore ans en 2021 et là
encore les frontières sont fermées ou
ont été fermés une bonne partie de
l'année mais il y avait des exemptions
pour les travailleurs étrangers
temporaires ils ont pu arriver et donc
ça montre qu'il ya une forte hausse donc
au québec de travailleurs étrangers est
en point c'est dû à deux éléments deux
facteurs clés le premier gerald vous en
parler je pense tous les jours à rdi
c'est la manoeuvre bien sûr donc il ya
d'énormes besoins dans des secteurs en
crise l'hôtellerie la restauration la
manufacture la liste elle est vraiment
longue et l'autre facteur important
c'est l'arrivée au pouvoir de françois
legault ce qu on a beaucoup parlé
d'immigration permanente avec françois
legault mais en coulisses en fait ce que
et c'est négocier simon jean la barrette
qui était l'ancien musée de
l'immigration c'était accueillir plus de
travailleurs étrangers temporaires et
les accueillir plus facilement en fait
donc c'est pour ça que toute cette
hausse finalement a été prévu calculé
imaginé et négocier en fait par la caq
depuis qu'elle est au pouvoir très
intéressant et une entente avec le
gouvernement fédéral devrait d'ailleurs
simplifier le processus comme ça de
recrutement à l'étranger ouais
effectivement on parle d'un
assouplissement qui était réclamée en
fait par le milieu des affaires depuis
plusieurs années on sait que faire venir
des travailleurs étrangers c'est à la
fois longs ça prend plusieurs mois et
c'est coûteux évidemment pour des
petites et des moyennes entreprises on
parle de 1000 1500 $ pour des frais de
dossier ensuite plusieurs milliers de
dollars évidemment pour les faire venir
directement au québec donc grosso modo
on a conclu une entente pour faire venir
plus d'immigrants temporaires et les
faire venir plus rapidement en
simplifiant les démarches donc à trois
mesures importantes qui ont été
instaurées par exemple pour les postes à
bas salaires donc à moins de 23 $ de
l'heure les entreprises dans certains
secteurs pourront faire venir deux fois
plus d'immigrants là on parle d'un seuil
qui passe de 10 % à 20 % donc ça c'est
dans le commerce de détail l'hébergement
la restauration ou encore la fabrication
de produits par exemple mais ce n'est
pas tout pour toute une série de
professions un employeur pourra
bénéficier de ce qu'on appelle un
traitement simplifié les démarches en
quelque sorte c'est le graal pour ses
employeurs parce que grosso modo ça veut
dire que pour des conducteurs de camions
pour des poids lourds des magasiniers
des préposés aux bénéficiaires débouchés
industriels ou des opérateurs de
machines l'entreprise n'aura plus de
seuil de travailleurs étrangers
temporaires dont qu'elle pourrait
embaucher autant qu'elles le souhaitent
elle n'aura pas de preuve d'effort de
recrutement également à fournir donc il
sera pas nécessaire de prouver qu'on a
tenté de chercher des travailleurs au
québec et la troisième mesure c'est une
exemption du processus d'affichage pour
certaines autres professions la plus
concrètement ça signifie qu actuellement
pour faire venir des travailleurs
étrangers temporaires il faut faire un
affichage donc prouvé pendant un mois
qu'on n'a pas trouvé de travailleurs
disponibles au québec et au canada donc
plusieurs professions à bas salaire là
encore seront exemptés de cette
obligation là donc ça va faciliter
évidemment le nombre de travailleurs
étrangers temporaires pour qu'ils
puissent venir au québec dans les
prochains mois tout ça devrait entrer en
vigueur début 2010 22 il va y avoir une
grosse également du nombre d'immigrants
permanent à reprocher aux moyens on le
sait que françois legault avait dans sa
promesse dit on en prend moins et on en
prendra soin dont on avait une baisse de
10 mille immigrants permanent donc on
était passé à 40000 maintenant grosso
modo jusqu'à l'année prochaine on va
revenir au seuil de l'ère libérale donc
sous philippe couillard donc grosso modo
50 mille immigrants permanent l'adsa va
savoir s'ajouter le rattrapage on que
l'équipe de françois legault a prévu de
faire venir immigrant permanence
supplémentaire pour rattraper ceux qui
n'ont pas pu venir pendant la pandémie
donc si on ajoute les immigrants
temporaire plus les immigrants permanent
par exemple cette année on peut imaginer
qu'ils entre 80 et 90 milles immigrants
au total qui vont arriver au québec
cette année et aucun autre gouvernement
ni au parti québécois ni au parti
libéral n'ont fait ou non réussi à faire
venir autant d'immigrants que françois
legault très intéressant un portrait
complet merci romain avec plaisir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit